you mentioned your leg I want to bring
this up quickly because I actually know
someone who went through the same
procedure you were born one leg uh
shorter than the other is that right
yeah when I was born they were even but
as I got taller
um my right leg just couldn't keep up
for some reason and yeah by the time I
was full grown it was almost two inches
shorter than the left leg wow wow so
yeah there's a procedure I think they
still do it called the eliteroff date
procedure they still do it and I I know
um good friends of ours uh their child
went through it
and it's when you hear about it it
almost sounds medieval yeah this
procedure but it works yeah you want to
describe it it's it's pretty basic they
uh
um it in my case it was my femur so that
they uh they uh cut they cut your femur
in half and then they screw this cage
around around your your leg and into
your bone
and then uh every day you turn four
screws on this cage and it kind of
separates either end of it a millimeter
so over the course of a couple months
it's separated to two inches and and the
bone as it's doing that the Bone's kind
of growing in the middle oh my God wow
but it must be I mean is that incredibly
painful to turn those screws
um yeah it was pretty painful yeah I
mean I'm I know I asked a really stupid
question and I'll own that but
um and I'll admit that I knew the answer
but I
I wanted you
I I just I I cannot believe
and I as I said I know someone who went
through this and it was very successful
but I really I really felt for this
young woman and I felt for the parents
because I just thought I can't imagine
turning those screws every day
um yeah it's I yeah I feel sad when I
think about a little kid doing it and I
saw kids at the hospital doing it same
time as me and it's yeah I feel bad for
him
um because they didn't you know I signed
up for it I wanted to do it I was
excited but it worked it was successful
well it didn't work but that's the thing
is it works a lot better for kids their
bones just grow and uh even for me at 25
already the bone just wasn't filling in
so
um I had to screw it back together again
and then start over and start stretching
it and uh it still didn't grow so they
ended up after a year or that they took
uh some bone out of my hip grounded up
and and stuck it into the space between
the two halves of my femur and then that
finally took
oh my god
um
sorry I'm sorry I just took my breath
away that is no I'm I mean I I'm sorry
you went through that
uh but my God it just you know can you
ask him again if it was painful well
okay
I actually do so you think a little
aspirin what leave what do you do no um
I I took a a wonderful uh opiate called
Demerol oh uh I I'd had no experience
with those kind of pills uh until that
point and yeah I really came to love it
I
I'm hoping you still don't love it I'm
hoping that I I try my best to avoid
those kind of painkillers if at all
possible because they're so good
um I do have to say and I've been on
record as saying this before the few
times in my life when I've required a
professional level Major League
painkiller or opiate
um
I've been the happiest I've ever been in
my life and that's a terrible thing to
and no one should do them but I like I
understood I understood yeah where Keith
Richards and everyone was coming from
but no terrible and the other Silver
Lining is the way it affected my voice
so on our second record I actually
wanted to do the vocals when I was in
the middle of this procedure and man
there's something in my voice just I can
hear what I've gone through and and the
physical suffering it comes out and in
this very beautiful sad tone in my voice
and there's just I don't think there's
any other way to get that you know it's
uh such a cliche the Hunger Artist that
great art has to come you know there has
to be pain and everyone has their own
version of that but
um uh you know and clearly I don't wish
pain on anybody but
uh something does come from this I would
think do you agree with that that you
get something I mean other than just a
longer leg you that this is somehow
influential in your creative process or
no it depends on how you feel about that
album because it I mean it was a big
flop when it came out still a lot of
people don't like it you don't hear it
on the radio but
for other people it's their favorite
Weezer album and there's there's
something really special on it there's
uh I love it and there's I know at the
time it was not considered it was not a
commercial success and critics didn't
like it I think it's been re-evaluated
since then yeah I'm a little skeptical
because I feel like the only people who
bother to go back and reevaluate an
album from 1996 are the people who kind
of already love it I'd like to ask the
people who gave it such bad reviews when
it originally came out hey what do you
think of it now yeah it's hard to I mean
who knows what they're doing now like
yeah yeah well that's they may not still
be reviewing music
um I mean that's the other thing I
learned early on is
with criticism is is uh
um
try not to hold grudges try not to they
just felt so destructive to me and I
don't want to have a dialogue with
people who
whatever they didn't like what I was
doing in 93 and 94 and there were a lot
of people who didn't and I understand
where they were coming from
um I just decided to keep going and if I
ran into them today I would like to
think I'd have a pleasant conversation
with them you know and because I don't
want to have that hey man why didn't you
like are you thinking of someone
specific
there's too many actually okay there's
there's too many people I uh
um that's weird because as a somebody
who's just watching your show back then
it would never have occurred to me
there's people that don't like you oh
sweet uh well it was generational
um you mean the older people uh yeah
there was a stat you know and and we um
and I understood where it was coming
from because I really came out of
nowhere and I was very unpolished and
I can see it I can see why people would
uh what I loved which really meant a lot
to me is very young people were
completely they were not judgmental at
all they just saw the weird stuff we
were doing and thought Oh this is for us
uh I like this but uh it was
very uh discordant I think to a whole
generation and uh and it really upset
people
and um
and at the time I I hated going through
that but now it just it's part of the
story and uh made my peace with it and
so
um but I know what that's I know that
situation or that feeling of you put
something out there
and you know you drop that Penny down
the well and there's
you know you don't hear the splash you
don't get the response he wanted and uh
so
and I think would be
it's so funny because I just think of
throwing it back to you Weezer you bet
you guys have endured for so long and
done such good work and there's so much
great stuff there that you have a
conversation with anybody I don't see
you know nobody knows or really cares
how your second album was received do
you know what I mean which is the way
which is really nice they're looking at
the whole they're looking at the body of
work